What can I take for H. Pylorite?
Well, that was a question last week that I waited to detail and I have a blog post about H. Pylorite, too
So make sure you look at the blog about H. Pylorite
Top things for H. Pylorite would be you know, or a god grape
Burberry
Or regga-do
garlic
Those would be the top things that you would take for H. Pylorite
And then at leaky got has come back to challenge my digestion so
You know, everybody has issues with leaky got and you know just because of our America diet the level of toxicity that we're living with
The level of cross contamination with glyphosate
glyphosate is the biggest thing that's going to damage your gut lining
And we're all exposed to that probably on a daily basis
So we have to always be working on leaky got so there's a lot of leaky gut supplements out there
things with slippery elment and
marshmallow root and
Decloserized licorice and so I like a product called GI sood
It's a zyvogen product because it's just a tablet that you put in your mouth and you dissolve it
It's a chocolate flavored tablet super easy to take
But there's other products the only thing you have to be careful with with cancer diagnosis a lot of he got healing products
We'll have el glutamated it you don't want to be taking
um
That at least you don't want to be taking high doses that for very long period of time with cancer diagnosis because
I'll go to be to such a
growth factor to cancer
But I do have videos and blog posts on both of these so make sure you look at that. I go into that in greater detail